okay so House of the Dragon season 1 had
a big ending and episode 10 set up a lot
of things for the future season 2 is
rumored to be two years away and if he
can't wait that long then this is the
video for you throughout it we're gonna
be going through what happens in the
book what to expect for the future and
also just our general theories on what
the outline of the season will be
because of this there will be heavy
spoilers so if you don't want anything
ruined then I'll recommend that you turn
off now if you enjoy the video the
thumbs up is much appreciated and make
sure you bend the knee and subscribe for
more breakdowns like this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our house of the
Dragon season 2 predictions
[Music]
okay so season one actually set up a
number of things in its final few scenes
we had Damon going to Verma Thor Raines
flying off and yasaris also going off on
his own mission too these all have major
ramifications for what's coming down the
line I think that the season will open
with us following Jace as he tries to
Rally support for his mother he ends up
visiting two locations in the area and
also winter pal at the first of these he
meets Lady Jane and similar to an Era
people don't believe she should be in a
position of leadership there's lots of
accounts over their interaction with one
even saying that the lady would swear
enough if Jace could bring her to climax
with his tongue the book's words not
mine now having never married there was
a lot of rumors about her sexuality and
I think she sort of meant to mirror
Queen Elizabeth from her own history she
sees a lot of similarities in rhaenyra
and basically wants sisters to stick
together so she agrees to swearing out
the hair Jace also visits Winterfell I
think this would be a great place to
start things off the location is of
course really iconic when we're talking
Game of Thrones and it would bring the
Starks back into the fold after they
made a brief appearance at the end of
episode 1. monken's true telling says
that Craig and Stark and Ja Harris got
on like a house that had just had
dracara said to it and they became good
friends I was a really bad joke now the
work says the prince reminded the Lord
of Winterfell of his younger brother who
had sadly died 10 years before it says
they drank together hunted together
trained together and sworn oath of
Brotherhood sealed in Blood Bad Boys for
Life anyway there's also an additional
comment by mushroom that could possibly
be brought into the show this talks
about a girl like Jace ended up marrying
whilst he was out there and we learned
her name was Sarah snow referred to as a
wolf girl she was said to be the bastard
of Lord Rick and Stark and the pair got
it on they had spoken their vows in
winterfell's own godswood before a heart
tree and only then had she given herself
to him wrapped in Furs amidst the snow
as the old gods looked on the book does
say that the entire character may just
be a fabrication but I think that they
will lean into it in the show the series
introduced the Valerian dagger which
wasn't in the book and with her being
called Sarah snow it might try and lean
into the whole Jon Snow thing at
Winterfell look I don't know origin's
story is all over the place and that's
why I'm keeping this solidly
now on the other side of this we have
stuff carrying over from the death of
lucerys in the book they start off a
major retaliation from renira's side and
Damon promised her there would be a sun
for his son he went to my zarya and she
ended up sending two assassins into the
red keep it's something we've talked
about in depth numerous times and I
don't want to just keep repeating myself
every video so if you want a full
breakdown of what goes on then that'll
be linked in our horrifying moment video
the gist of it is though that two
assassins make Helena choose which of
her children has to die she picks the
youngest malor and the Assassins instead
kill her eldest Sonja Harris Elena goes
insane as she has one son that died and
another who knows that his mother picked
him to be murdered Helena can't even be
around her children due to the guilt and
eventually these are taken away from her
and put in the care of Allison I can't
see their murder being a big thing that
closes out episode 1 and it could bounce
off the back of Jace learning his
brother is dead whilst we see the
consequences of it it's pretty much the
Red Wedding of Fire and Blood and it
would be a massive way to start off the
new season this basically leaves team
green hitting some hard times and if
you'd like to show your support for them
we actually have a team green t-shirt
linked below Eamon didn't know what he
was doing Alison was just scared of kids
were gonna get murdered in Otto he just
didn't want Damon on the throne look he
murdered his wife yeah he strangled the
next one and that's why I'm Team Green
and why you should be too support by
buying this shirt Linked In the
description celebrate with us and don't
buy that red and black shirt Greg is
pushing at real rejects because the
guy's a scumbag now aegon Wants Revenge
for this and continuing this eye for an
eye mentality he puts his own plans into
place they go to our Cargill and come up
with a plan for him to do an old
Switcheroo Eric sneaks into Dragonstone
dressed as a fisherman and he goes over
the castle disguised as his brother the
story says that the pair looked so
similar that no one could tell them
apart and because of this Eric is able
to just walk through the entire location
without getting questioned he's
instructed to kill a member of the
Royals but the maesters that made the
book don't know whether it's rhaenyra or
another kid we never find out as Eric
comes across his brother whilst he makes
his way through and the pair end up
having a fight guards and onlookers
surround them but as they can't tell
either apart they can't just jump in and
kill Eric it's said that both told the
other brother that they loved him before
the pair juked it out and this story has
been chronicled in several songs as I'm
sure you can guess they both dealt
killing blows to each other and died
during this fight now from this point
onwards raniera's side really starred to
gain some ground Sarah the Lords that
had sworn themselves to aegon started to
wonder whether they'd made the right
decision and there was very much unrest
amongst his followers so far he'd been
trying to charm his allegiances and he'd
been resting on The Laurels that because
he was a man that they just joined him
it was very much sexism and Kingdom and
this led to a frosky reception once they
started to change sides Kristen and
still in him that he should become an
attack dog that shows four course and
this would very much give a warning to
those who didn't support him what fight
they'd be in for if they didn't stay
loyal aegon then stripped the hand of
the king badge from his grandfather Otto
and he passed it over to Kristen now on
the other side of this we're probably
gonna follow on from the event set up by
Damon and Verma Thor he was last seen
going to the caves at Dragonstone in
order to sing to the Beast that he'd be
getting a new Riders soon Burma Thor was
originally to Harris's dragon and after
the king died he retreated the caves to
live without a rider Damon went to him
and he also tried to round up the other
dragons on the island in order to
strengthen their forces this was
something known as the sowing though it
would later be called the red sewing due
to all the people that got killed trying
to mount the dragons amongst them was
Stefan darklin one of the nights we got
to know a bit better in episode 10.
anyway there's a bit where they
basically round up all the bastards on
Dragonstone some sound a bit like Robert
barathe in there with a scene bastards
what I mean by this is that the castle
was surrounded by villagers that the
Targaryen royalty used to constantly
free frequent they'd come down from the
castle get drunk and sleep with people
in the village and this would eventually
lead to several bastards being created
these were known as the dragon seeds and
they were basically seen as people who
had Dragon blood in them so they could
Mountain ride the beasts these were all
gathered up and there was an attempt to
get as many Dragon Riders as they could
this is when we'll likely be introduced
to Hugh Hammer who's a big character in
the book he ends up being the writer
that climbs on the back of Verma Thor
and this becomes his Dragon Damon also
takes over harrenhal and this becomes a
major hold in the war now I can see this
all happening in the early part of the
season with us then getting a big battle
in the middle involving rainis when we
last saw her she was flying out on
Patrol on the back of her dragon and
this was to protect the Valerian Fleet
renise helped out a lot but I can't see
her making it to the end of season 2.
renice went to Rook rest and at this
point the location was attacked by
Kristen Cole aymond and also Prince
aegon Middle East had no chance against
their dragons but renice turned around
and stood her ground this is probably
going to be the first time that we see
aegon's Dragon Sunfire who was held back
from season one though he was mentioned
he was meant to appear at the coronation
but the show had this being interrupted
by rhaenis the pair met in the air and
then fell to the ground with maylese
dying in the attack there was a Bend
body found next to the dragon but it was
so blackened that it couldn't be
identified again was also severely
injured during this and it said that his
armor was melted to the point that it
actually fused with his skin half of his
body was burned and because of this he
had to rest up Eamon took over the
throne and as season one showed us he
does think he'd be a better King from
here I can see the season culminating
with the death of jiserus and therefore
the ending of it will mirror the ending
of season 1 with his brother luceris the
book has this happening during an event
known as the battle of the gullet since
season one's NTS towards this being
protected by corliss's Fleet I think the
seats will be shown for this being a big
Showdown down the line Jason four dragon
seeds rolled out to help and during this
fight bermax flew too low and he was
struck by crossbows and grapnels this
pulled the dragon into the sea where
joserus tried to swim he clung onto some
ships wreckage and was struck by
crossbow bolts which ended his life now
whilst all this was going on renera also
manages to take King's Landing but I
don't know if they're gonna have time
for that in the season who knows though
but based off the book those are my
thoughts on what we'll be seeing next
time obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you comment below
and let me know if you are in
competition right now giving away three
copies of top gun Maverick on the 15th
of November and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe and
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on where things
are going we pick the comments out
random on the 15th and the winnings of
the last one are on screen right now say
that to you message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch make sure you check out
our breakdown of episode 10 which will
be linked on the screen right now lots
of things to talk about it's one of our
videos ever so definitely go head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace